the next point of the agenda is the
declaration of the european council and
the european commission
uh the preparation for the meeting of
the european council of the 21st to the
22nd of october 2021 i'd like to remind
all colleagues that for all the debates
of this partial session there is not
going to be a catch ti procedure and
blue cards will not be accepted and also
as has
happened um we will see some
interventions remotely from different
lies and offices of the parliament in
the different member states i'll start
therefore by
welcoming and giving the floor to anza
logar on behalf of the council the
minister for foreign fest
president
president of the commission
honorable members
for tomorrow leaders will meet in
brussels for the october european
council
where they will discuss the key issues
facing the eu and its citizens today and
in the future
the meeting will of course start with
the usual exchange with the european
parliament
leaders will discuss the current state
of play on covet 19. the vaccination
rollout in the eu has been largely
successful
but more needs to be done
especially regarding vaccination
hesitancy and disinformation
further coordination is also needed with
regard to free movement and travel to
the eu
given the global nature of the pandemic
and the emergence of new variants
international solidarity remains
important
rapid removal of obstacles hampering the
global rollout of vaccines and it is
crucial to allow member state to speed
up delivery of vaccines to countries
most in need
covet 19 has taught us that we need to
be better prepared for the pandemics of
the future in this context leaders are
expected to call for the conclusion of
the negotiation on the health union
legislative package
member states continue to support a
strong and central low role of the who
in global health governance as well as
the creation of an international treaty
on pandemics
the hike in energy prices is without a
doubt one of the most pressing issues
for our citizens and industry today
following their informal dinner in
bordeaux in slovenia leaders will
discuss recent developments in energy
prices and possible measures at eu and
national level taking into account the
recent commission communication
the commission has identified various
measures that are at disposal on the
national level
to mitigate and mitigate the effect of
soaring energy prices
in addition to that we also expect the
leaders to take a closer look at what
could be of help at the european level
both short term as well as in the medium
and long term to reduce our dependency
on fusil fuel
at a more strategic level leaders are
expected to have an open discussion on
trade
when it comes to the eu global influence
trade remains the most effective
instrument in our toolbox
leader will discuss how to make the best
use of this instrument in light of
recent experiences
literally also assess the implementation
of the june european council conclusions
on the external dimension of migration
eight action plans for countries of
origin and transit have been presented
now these plans need to be made
operational and implemented without
delay
leaders are expected to call on the
commission to present proposals for
financing action on all migratory routes
and to present regularly to report
regularly to the council in this regard
europe's digital transformation is also
on the agenda as it is an important
driver of economic growth job creation
and competitiveness
leaders will take stock of progress on
digital agenda
including cyber security and
connectivity and give a political push
to work on existing and future proposals
and initiatives
inclusive and sustainable digital
policies and digital connectivity remain
important
with regard to external relations
leaders will discuss the preparation for
the upcoming assam summit in november
and the eastern partnership summit in
december
the prime objective of the eastern
partnership summit is to demonstrate the
importance of the relationship with
eastern partners a united eu position is
essential if we want to engage this
partner successfully the light motif of
re-silence recovery and reform
should guide the way
in view of the upcoming cop 26 summit
leaders are expected to call for an
ambitious global response to climate
change
urging major economies
that have not yet done
so to set ambitious national determined
contributions in time for cop 26
to present long-term strategy for
reaching net zero emissions by 2050
and to meet their commitment on climate
finance
we will come back to cop 26 in our next
debate
leaders will also call for an ambitious
post 2020 global biodiversity
framework ahead of next year's cop 15
meeting on biodiversity in kunming
i look very much forward to hear your
opinion on this important matters and
thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much mr logar and now i
give the floor to the president of the
european commission also love underlined
thank you madam president
minister
honourable members
we will be discussing many important
topics at tomorrow's european council
one certainly will be indeed covet
i think here to take stock is an
important moment because we have reached
now 1 billion of doses of vaccines that
have been exported from the european
union and this is exceptional because we
are the only region in the world the
only one
who kept exporting doses through all
doses of vaccine through all
the different difficult month we have
just overcome
so we have been able really to keep our
promise to say every second doses that
is being produced in europe will be
exported by now it's to 150
countries in the world
we will also be discussing of course
different topics like cyber or the
digital
the polish debate we had yesterday so i
will not focus on that i wanted to focus
today on the topic of electricity prices
very important for us
and here let me begin with three simple
facts
the first fact is that gas prices are
and have always been cyclical
and they are set by global markets so
it's not a regional or local phenomenon
it's a global phenomenon but of course
we see because of the price rise in gas
we see that it is for many families now
difficult to make ends meet
and we see businesses for example at
risk of closing
the second fact is that the renewables
are on a winning path
if you look at the solar energy today
it's 10 times cheaper than it was 10
years ago
and if you look
at wind power which is by definition
more volatile
it is today 50 percent cheaper than a
decade ago
and the third topic is the question of
import
and here we see if we look at gas 90 of
the gas we use is imported
actually 97 of the oil
renewables are home grown
so these three facts show us
that the transition to clean energy is
not only vital for our planet
it is also crucial for our economy and
for the resilience to energy price
shocks
now what are the causes of the current
spikes first of all the global economy
recovers from the pandemic and of course
with that the energy demand is rising
second we had an unusually
long and cold winter so lots of heating
followed by an unusual hot summer so
lots of cooling and use of energy and
this was a fact in the entire northern
hemisphere
third
the whole world of course is affected so
that means irrespective of countries
energy or climate policies or the
climate the energy mix they have
they are affected by the rise of energy
prices and electricity prices we see
and in fact we see that the prices in
asia are even higher than they are here
in europe
yet there is something specific to the
european situation
if we look at the gas and the suppliers
while gas prompt has honored its
long-term contracts with us
it did not respond to higher demand as
it did in previous years
so europe is today too reliant on gas
it is too demand dependent on gas
imports as i said we import 90 percent
of the gas we use and this makes us
vulnerable
the answer has to do with diversifying
the suppliers
but the answer also has to do with
keeping the role of natural gas as a
transitional fuel we have to debate that
in depth
and crucially of course we're speeding
up the transition to clean energy
so the european green deal
is in the mid and long term
a crucial pillar
of european energy sovereignty in the
21st century
but of course i was speaking about the
mid and long term rightly so citizens
expect us to act now they want quick
responses and therefore let me turn to
the measures
we are deploying to address the
situation first of all at the short term
our priority is to give relief to
vulnerable families
and businesses
some measures can be taken very swiftly
under the current eu rules
this incl includes relief for business
or families if you look at the business
of course i'm talking about the smes
through state aid through targeted
support to consumers and
cuts of levy and taxes
because i want to remind ourselves that
if you look at the price itself on
average one-third of the wholesale
energy price is set by the market so
it's a market price one-third one-third
depends on infrastructure
but one-third on average depends on
taxes and levies there are some member
states where 50
are taxes and levies on the
electricity price
so this is where member states can act
very quickly
and by now 20 of our member states are
also doing that
metro
electricity
in premier evaluation of the system
a la liga del experience actually
dissimilable
formula
ensuite the recommendations
a
honorable members
science has been telling us for years
that we must accelerate the
transition towards a carbon neutral
economy
now the economy is adding another reason
to do so
the upcoming cop 26 in glasgow will be
the moment for the whole world to speed
up action
because the world is not yet on track to
match our commitments under the paris
agreement we should be fully aware of
that
so much more needs to be done to prevent
global temperatures from rising more
than 1.5 degrees over pre-industrial
levels
the european union will bring to glasgow
the highest level of ambition and we do
it for all future generations we do it
for our planet and we do it for europe
thank you
thank you
very much president van der lyon and now
i'll
start the round of the different
political groups starting with the
european people's party group i give the
floor to esther de lange
yes thank you madam vice president um
i think we cannot start this debate
today about the upcoming european
council without looking back at
yesterday's debate with prime minister
moravietsky
because at this council clearly the rule
of law risks being the elephant in the
room
and let me remind all of you of article
15 of the treaty the european council
shall provide the union with the
necessary impetus for its development
and shall define the general political
directions and priorities
thereof on the rule of law we've heard
the commission yesterday and we thank
you for that
but the european count